[Music]
good morning thanks for coming we're
going to talk about geeky sandbox for
multi-tenancy and security in this
session how many people went to the
party last night
Oh quite a bit thank you for coming
after that you know Harding you play
around at the party huh I kind of miss
you but we have a lot to kind of cover
today so let's get started so first we
should introduce ourselves team we want
to go first sure thanks my name is Tim
Kelton and I'm the co-founder of
Descartes labs and I work on building
tools to model and understand the earth
and the other part of my job is doing
all of our cloud architecture and our
sree and security teams
alright thanks team so then my turn so
hi I'm Yoshi I'm product manager on
kubernetes engine I work on G visor
multi-tenancy and machining stuff like
GPU and cloud compute engine k next
scene I have I'm Ian Lewis I'm a
developer advocate I focus on GK and
container security cool sorry let's then
begin but before we begin we would like
to know about you as well somebody asked
this question so how many of you think
yourself as like an application
developer or DevOps or sree Oh
many people I will say like a like 80%
of people ok and then how many of you
think is security engineering like folks
is you interesting like 10 or 20% I
think ok how many of you actually wear
both hats at the same time there you go
my customer Tim here ok that's
interesting so the reason I asked this
question comes from my like experience
meeting with users customers like
yourself I feel lucky that I can have an
interaction with you all the time and
one thing I realized is that there are
like two sides when you know when I go
to this kind of meetings one side is
like developers application doubler
devops esters who really care about
speed and flexibility or force those
people who like containers and
kubernetes and the other side security
folks who of course you're deeply care
about
security apparently and as you can
imagine frequently kind of feel that
there are some challenges between these
two Brewers when it comes down to making
important like engineering and
architecture decision for example
container or not crew grannies or not
sharing crew grenades or not coking
clusters or not right so let's see that
you know where this kind of a you know
challenge come from we believe that's
because fundamentally containers do not
contain we've been saying this actually
from last year but this means that while
containers are really really great for
speed and flexibility to increase your
productivity it's actually not in a
security isolation boundary for your
work clothes that means that many you
know like a lot of you on in this room
on the security folks or the query both
hats have to harden the containers
end-to-end and that could mean a lot of
work
you can certainly hard on your
containers through policies and do the
right thing however technically you know
maintaining this or doing this right
could be very very challenging sometimes
we all know that security is critical
and so you know it's also true that we
have a lot of things to keep in mind so
there is a constant amount when when I
go to customer meetings there's a
constant demand about security can we
just do it in just one click there's an
easy way it's totally totally
understandable in fact open source
software is growing everyone appreciated
using some kind of open source and
that's really cool a lot of features
come in and it reflects users voices
very quickly but when it comes down to
actually using production using on your
own it's actually your responsibility
you have to me mostly security team has
to actually be in charge of assuring its
integrity also on top of that the
vulnerability is around containers keep
coming up which all getting you know dig
deeper most recently there was a run
sale container escaping run see how many
people kind of heard about this oh yeah
this one is actually kind of wily um
mentioned so it's pretty understandable
so just for the I'll just explain a
little bit more Runcie is the engine of
the container runtime like docker
container a container D and cryo and in
this case if the attackers process was
running as root inside a container the
attacker was able to gain the root
access of the host by overriding around
C minor from inside an obvious way to
mitigate this threat was to run the
container as non true of course and
apparently this was this is definitely
sort of the way in the recommended way
running your containers in the first
place however now even if you did run
your containers as non-root you still
need to think about the container escape
through the Linux kernel so not many
people know about it but NYADA has a
huge attack surface and this type of
continuous cake can happen by exploiting
the bugs inside a Linux kernel and if
the attack was successful the attacker
may but maybe it might may be able to
bypass the container mechanism or
elevate the / elevate the privilege it's
privileged one of the most well known
case of this is dirty cow this is a
privilege escalation using a bug and
Linux kernel by exploiting a race
condition in the copyright system cow in
the memory system a memory subsystem the
non-local user was able to increase
their privileges on the system so again
containers do not contain thus you
should you would definitely want to
think about running running only trusted
code in your system
now if your system we're on trusted code
you know you're you're falling to write
best practice and you know you know
lower privilege that's really great
however in case of sass and
multi-tenancy mana multi-tenancy things
don't this is your work that way if
you're running a sass like Tim my
customer your you know your customers
will be would like to upload their code
to run their favorite plugins or on your
service you know like in case of the for
example in our Google service like cloud
run could be a good example that we
launched you know you if you have you
have your functions or code their
service containers your you know custom
users will be uploading whatever code
they want to to your system and you as a
service provider want to share a cluster
to save the cost as a consequence
basically an untrusted code can be
running on the shared cluster by default
now therefore we need a solution and
there's a good news there are containers
actually do contain in there call
sandbox sandbox is a hot topic in
companies in fact there are a number of
sunburn sandbox technologies emerged in
open source in this until just last year
and a half and also in the kubernetes
world convenience runtime class was
added to provide an API to access to
this sandbox to sandbox your containers
you know inkling together with the new
technologies that's happening in an open
source world now open source
technologies are coming up and now the
question is do we have the product for
that with that we're very excited to
introduce a GK sandbox on google
kubernetes engine as the name says it
provides sandbox containers do contain
2gk it has defense enter at the pot
level it is based on open source advisor
which is which is what Google invented
and then it was so widely used in the
Google internally now since we open
Sergey Weiser you might heard about
product Google products that's me that's
using G Weiser most recent one is a
clown that we announced at next at the
keynote on the first day and one of the
reasons that gu g gk samba AG visor
that's back you know that's a that's a
powering g k sandbox because so popular
at google is that it does not require
any application changes if you have your
work clothes we have your containers you
don't necessarily have to change to get
your stuff sandbox so if you're thinking
about how to use this you don't have to
actually think about it one you know you
just have to turn it on and then run
your paws on gk sandbox so how can g ki
sandbox help you Jiki sandbox can help
you but you know it's really easy to use
it has defense and that without hassling
first of all it's part of gk the google
coronation is a managed coronary service
and it's the sticky sandbox is fully
integrated into gk thus you don't have
to install anything you don't have to
install open-source advisor it's all we
already baked in everything and we made
a toggle in the switch very simple that
we're gonna talk deeper so you can have
all the container if you're ready on gk
it's just a couple switch and there you
go in addition to that i just kind of
mentioned you know the end of technology
used behind the scene in sea visor and i
just like i mentioned you don't have to
change your application you know you
don't have to change your applications
or no not no new mental model to use it
you just run it as if you run your
regular you know you put your paws
regularly ii eliminates the potential
tax by reducing attack surface today the
container and the host operating system
are tied together
what GK sandbox provide is are two
layers isolation in between like this I
can't actually hold but a the first
layer of isolation a
the the usual and Colonel Redding go
that G adviser provides and then even if
that gets compromised there's additional
filter SEC comp and namespace that would
actually prevent further attack
so from here sitting together to two
layers in between we're gonna dig deeper
on this one as well
third G key sandbox can help teams who
want to run SAS and multi-tenancy
because it provides these strong
isolation boundaries for example like
cloud run that got announced again is
using G visor at the same technology
behind GK sandbox when you have such you
know untrusted code come in here and
there all the time
you do need isolation therefore you want
to think about this kind of technology
sandbox to be used in your system so I
think
Jiki sandbox should be a great fit for
those who are planning to go in
multi-tenancy or who have SAS similar to
Quran and many further services with
that I'm going to hand it over to you to
talk more about the technology back in
of GG sandbox which is the adviser that
is already on open source yeah okay so
I'm going to be talking about G visor
which is the open source project that is
what is used behind the scenes by by GK
sandbox so G visor is an open source
project container sandbox runtime and
what that is is a it's a OCI runtime
much like the like run see that if
you're familiar with that it's used
extensively at Google for a number of
different use cases but as you mentioned
for cloud it's used by for a certain
project products that run on trusted
code for it's like things like cloud run
on and our new app engine runtimes
as an open source project it's available
on github and we have a lot of
documentation of available at G visor
dev so if you're interested in
object definitely check out the website
we have lots of documentation on the
architecture the security model and lots
more and we'll also be whole we have
mailing lists and a community meeting
next week so if you're interested in
getting involved with the project
definitely checking it out all of that
information is on the the community page
on the website so to give some
background into gee visor and why we
developed it and the thinking behind it
we wanted to be able to run untrusted
code on behalf of users and but at
Google we use containers a lot as part
of our infrastructure and typically the
way that you would build a sandbox like
this is you would use some sort of
hardware isolation mechanism like a VM
or a virtual machine manager but that
doesn't really necessarily fit with our
architecture in a way that we liked and
we wanted to be much more container like
and for it to be something that really
was very resource efficient at scale so
we obviously need something that
provides us that defense-in-depth that
that extra layer of isolation but gave
us a lightweight way of running a
container we wanted something that was
very low overhead something that was
able to start and stop containers very
quickly and easily and we always wanted
something but we also wanted something
that was zero configuration so if you're
not using a VM M then usually you would
do something like using app armor or
seccomp which are tend to be based on
configuration or filtering and they
depend a lot on how the application
behaves right so you typically filter
out the things that the application
doesn't need to do but you need to
manage that configuration over time as
the application changes and it's very
important from a security standpoint
that you keep that configuration correct
right like if your application starts
doing less things you need to then
update it so that the filter includes
those things and it doesn't
it's very hard from a from a security
standpoint to make sure that all the
applications that you're deploying are
are managed correctly and we also wanted
to be able to run binaries unmodified we
didn't want to have to you know update
our applications with a new library or
link to a new thing in order to get the
applications to run we wanted to just be
able to run them run regular
applications that were built for for
Linux so we built G visor in order to
solve those problems and what this what
G visor does is it provides a user space
kernel that is run in user space with
your container and as it runs your
container or your container application
it intercepts the system calls that your
application makes and Hale does those in
user space so in that sense it's very
similar to something like user space
Linux but it's it's a totally new kernel
that's implemented a to go using the go
runtime and we chose go because it's a
very good you know run time it had
provides a lot of things like you know
garbage collection as well as as type
safety so things that that can help with
the security of the of the user space
kernel itself and each pod is isolated
with its own user space kernel so we
don't have a single user space kernel
for all containers and this keeps all
the containers isolated from each other
but by having this user space kernel
we're also isolating from the host so
that the host interaction is is is
greatly reduced and so we don't have
containers interacting with the host and
able to get host level privileges
so diving a little bit deeper into the
architecture for G visor G visor
provides an OCI runtime interface so
this is the OCI is the open containers
initiative and this is a standard for
running containers and so we provide a
OCI interface in the form of an
application called run SC and this is a
single binary that you can use to deploy
G visor and install it and so it's
basically a drop-in replacement for the
run SC the run C binary and when you run
the the container we start up the
container and in user space with our
user space kernel and we call this the
Sentry and then when the container runs
we use something called a platform
called in order to intercept the system
calls and reroute direct those into the
century and we reuse KVM and P trace as
our two platforms that we provide as
part of the open source project and then
on top of the sandbox itself we have the
sandbox held inside of a container a
normal host container which is using set
comp and namespaces in order to further
isolate from the host so as you
mentioned we have to isolation mat
layers one is the Sentry itself and the
user space kernel and the second is the
host itself and that and the the set
comp and namespaces that the host
provides and so in order to get control
the entire host you would need to break
through both of those isolation
boundaries in order to further from like
add isolation we have something called a
gopher which is a separate process or a
separate process that gets run when you
run the run SC container and that
provides file i/o so the sentry itself
does not have permission to open files
on a local file system so even if you
get control this entry you're not able
to write to the hosts file system and
gain extra privileges that way you have
to go through a separate process that is
the over 9-p in order to
right files and deal with with file i/o
this gives us an extra layer because
there's a lot of different types of
attack services and gives us that extra
two levels of isolation for file i/o as
well so that's G visor itself how does
that fit into G K sandbox and gke so
with GK e we provide a managed control
plane and API server and then each of
the nodes in the in the cluster is a GCE
VM and you can arrange those in node
pools so some node pool is a group of
servers in your cluster or worker nodes
in your cluster that have the same
configuration so the same machine type
and things like that and you can have
multiple node pools in your cluster and
so what GK sandbox allows you to do is
create node pools that have G visor
enabled so basically an extra check box
in the cloud console or an extra flag on
G cloud enables you to create a G visor
enabled node pool and then whenever when
you run your your nodes or you run your
workloads in the cluster and you specify
GG visor is the runtime then you can run
it will schedule and run your workloads
on your G visor node pool so let's drill
down into one of these these nodes each
of these nodes has a an agent the the qu
burning the couplet and that couplet is
responsible for running the workloads on
that on that VM or that worker node and
in order to run containers it uses an
external runtime in this case container
D which is high-level runtime and that
in turn uses OC I to run use a low-level
runtime in order to run containers so
typically this would be done using run C
but what we can do with our G visor
enabled pod or nodes is to swap that out
for G visor and this is enabled because
we're using the o CI as a as a standard
interface
so how do you use it from a user's
perspective so from a user's perspective
all you need to do is specify the
runtime class name as part of your pod
spec kubernetes provides what's called a
runtime class API which is a new API
that allows you to find different
runtimes that you can use within your
cluster and gke sandbox provides this
automatically when you create a node
pool that is jiva's are enabled so you
don't have to worry necessarily about
creating these runtime classes and
managing those those are more of a
system or a cluster administrator type
of a role but from a user's perspective
or an end you somebody wanting to learn
workloads all you need to do is put this
runtime class name of Jeevitha into your
your pod spec and then that will get run
in G visor when you submit that to the
API server so what kind of workloads are
good for G visor from a technical
perspective so G visor works really well
for things like microservices so things
that are very small and quick and needs
to come up and down and are highly
scalable and are as well as dense
so things that can take advantage of the
low overhead that G visor provides work
really well in G visor so if you're
running you know micro services that
make use of a lot of third-party code on
perhaps you're using something like no
GS and you have a lot of external
libraries that you're using or pretty
much any other type of language running
that in G visor might be a way of better
ensuring that you have some extra
isolation there it's also really good
for sass and server list workloads so
things that you're going to be running
code on a user's behalf so people upload
some code and you run it on their behalf
those those type of things like give you
a little bit of extra confidence that
you're not exposing your entire
infrastructure to the code that gets
uploaded
it's also really good for batch of
machine learning workloads Shoji visor
because it's running as a user space
kernel it's running directly on the CPU
and so CPU intensive workloads work
really well for it it also is really
good for applications that run on this
kind of complex user input so user input
that comes into the cut the application
and gets processed typically for things
like machine learning and batch those
those that data is user submitted so
things like uploaded images or uploaded
data and you typically don't really
think about want to think about like all
the different types of complex user
input that could come in and whether
well-crafted input could cause a
security issue with your application
you'd like to be able to just run it in
a sandbox and not have to think about
think that much about the the security
implications so let's take a look at the
software as-a-service a use case so I'm
going to switch over to a demo here so
what I've built here is I've built a an
application that is a wordpress software
as-a-service
it's a very simple service that allows
me to create a wordpress instance on and
run run that WordPress on behalf of my
users but what I want to do is I want to
be able to allow users to upload or
install any plugins that they want to as
part of their WordPress application and
those plugins can basically Contrave
continue contain arbitrary code right so
these are these are plugins that are
available on the WordPress marketplace
and are not really vetted by me in terms
of like their security and that that
sort of thing so what I want to do is be
able to have allow people to create
their own plugins to install plugins on
the marketplace without having to worry
too much about these security
implications so what I can do here is I
can create a new WordPress
and call that Ian's blog and I can
create any number of these I'll create
Yoshi's blog too and what this is going
to do this is implemented as a simple
controller in kubernetes so this creates
a CRD that then gets kicked off and
creates some pods for me in my cluster
and so if I go over here and I look at
the the state of the cluster and we can
see that I've got two node pools here
and these are the this is a listing of
the nodes I first have my default pool
which is just a non G visor enabled node
pool and then I have a second node pool
that is enabling G visor here and so if
I go ahead and get the pods that are
running in my cluster I can see that
I've started the WordPress for my my
blog and I've started the WordPress for
my free yoshi's blog and we can see that
the WordPress blogs are running in our G
visor node pool we can also see that if
we if we get the pod here
we can see that our runtime class name
here is specified as divisor so that
means that it's running our our workload
as part of the inside of G vizor itself
great
alright so our blogs are up and running
so let's go ahead and click on our blog
here and so what we'll have is we'll
have like a brand new blog that's
running inside of inside of G Weiser and
it's taking a little bit to connect here
hmmm striae she's blog alright so we go
ahead and click English let's say the
slice title is Yoshi's blog create that
this guy go ahead and install and login
to our new WordPress and so this is a
fully functioning WordPress site and so
what we can do here we can go in and add
new plugins so we can install basically
any plugin we want here like a classic
editor you know and have that install
and activate without having to worry too
much about like what that actually
contains in terms of the code that's
included in it so what I'm gonna do here
is I'm actually upload a new plugin that
i want to installed it to my friend Tim
gave me and this one's called dirty cow
I'm not sure really sure what's in it
but I'm just gonna go ahead and install
it cuz he said it's really cool so if I
install this guy it installs excessively
okay so let's like go ahead and click on
this activate here when we do that it
kind of sits here and spins for a while
I don't know if you can see this but
it's sitting here in spinning but if we
kind of go into our logs we can see that
it's not quite up yet but what this is
doing in the background is it's actually
running the the dirty cow exploit as a
all right here we can see it so it's
actually running dirty cow trying to
attempt to take over my WordPress
installation so so we can see here we're
running the dirty cow exploit and what
dirty cow does is it uses em advise and
P trace desist
calls in and running those in parallel
in order to try to take advantage of the
system and take advantage of a of a runt
of a bug in the linux kernel in order to
actually take control of the whole
system well you know this is kind of an
old bug and that most Linux systems are
patched nowadays this is just a good
example of the type of class of a bug
that the gee visor can prevent and that
that it helps mitigate all right so
let's go back let's go back to the
slides yeah so next I want to have to I
want to have have Tim come up and talk
about machine learning and the use cases
around that and what he's been doing
yeah thanks Ian
you like my plugin so many I don't know
if any of you have heard of decart labs
but we're a start-up that's a few years
old we've about four years old now and
we're kind of focused on the area of
machine learning and on being able to
better observe the earth and our
background is we're kind of
stereotypical startup we're up in the
mountains of Santa Fe New Mexico and
we're there because myself and the
founding team were out of Los Alamos
National Laboratory and there we are
researchers in like high-performance
supercomputing astrophysics and among
them it you know we did research in
things like machine learning and being
able to apply that to remote sensing
data and we do that because and we
started the company to basically be able
to understand how change is happening
all over the world will start to impact
our our customers and their businesses
their organizations and even their
supply chain and I don't have to go
around and tell you there's a
proliferation of sensors all of you have
phones and you know all about IOT
and things like that and that's on the
ground but we're having that same
parallel explosion and sensor technology
happening on space and so we're getting
better and better resolution more and
more modalities better temporal coverage
and it's just getting cheaper and
cheaper these used to be half billion
dollar instruments that NASA put up
now there's grad departments that are
making bees and they're startups here in
the bay that are just launching them so
what's that's gonna do is that's going
to change how we can observe and measure
the earth and fundamentally changing a
lot of the workflows so a lot of the
data sets we leverage are really
scientific in nature they come from
places like NASA or European Space
Agency but more and more we're just
seeing that hit on the commercial level
and this new type of workflow is totally
different than historically what
happened historically you would you know
have an analyst and they would pull down
an image onto their desktop well that
worked great when you had four scenes
that were captured once a month and
things like that but we've long past
when the images and the data that was
being captured was humanly observable
and that's the type of machine workflows
that we're trying to leverage so things
like drought and food supply and famine
and water precious commodities that go
into building everything around us those
are what impacts us and so this is kind
of this new digital twin of the planet
that we're trying to measure and
understand and a lot of we have you know
probably nearly 20 petabytes of data now
that's stored up in the cloud that we
run and iterate on models so that's
great we never could do that before
without the cloud but you know it does
create some challenges what we did was
originally make these api's for our own
machine learning team so they could
scale up and test datasets
test models against these huge data sets
and it when we run our so we built our
SAS platform obviously on the cloud and
often it's not just those data sets that
our customers want to use they want to
build their own models they want to
often use one of their pieces of data to
get new insights for their company so I
thought I'd show you some examples this
is going to be lots of pictures hope
that's ok it's Thursday so this is a
solar facility in in Morocco it's pretty
amazing to look at but often it's
temporally how things change that give
us those insights and and we need to be
able to understand so obviously this is
a construction and the building of that
facility
another example is showing you know
patterns of life often we need to fuse
together different sensors and not just
one so in the top row is just normal red
green and blue like all of us as humans
can see but the bottom row is fusing
together infra red and you notice on the
far bottom-right one of the big things
you can't see with just human visible
light is that thermal signature we do
this for all different types of examples
we're starting to now run a wildfire
detection algorithm that will run over
the entire western half of the u.s. we
don't know exactly where a wildfire
might happen being able to detect those
thermal signatures is important this is
another example this is more in the kind
of computer vision and types of things
that you would use
you know tensorflow or those types of
tools this is a model that can detect
buildings and structures and last last
fall there were some hurricanes that
were heading toward Florida and so we
were saying well
could we actually scale this model
across the whole state of Florida so
that took us a couple hours and and
that's across hundreds of terabytes of
data so why might you also want to use
or know about where all the buildings
are being produced well construction
takes raw materials and those correlate
into commodities and and demand
structures so in this case steel and
again this is just things that weren't
really visible or weren't very easy to
measure without tremendous amounts of
computing power and that massive data
that's being collected water already
talked about that bit once before this
is a different modality we are sending a
radar signal down to the earth it
bounces off the Earth's surface it gives
us almost a height measurement you can
see Heights and reservoirs and and areas
like that you think about how many areas
water is an input to a pattern of life
so that's everything from food and food
supply and the types of models we build
there and those of us that live in
places like the West western half of the
u.s. is New Mexico California we know
how volatile water supply can be once
you know about buildings you might care
about trees or encroachment of trees
looking down and being able to identify
a tree versus vegetation is actually
really hard they both look like
vegetation that's growing there's
photosynthesis occurring you can see
both of them the same this is a place
where we were able to take light our to
train and see the height and then be
able to differentiate and apply this to
places where we didn't have light our
coverage and basically run this over the
whole globe and again you think about
last summer out here in California look
at some of the devastating fires we were
able to scale and run this model and map
out every single tree in the entire
state of California so that's just it
took lots and lots of computing
horsepower and lots of storage but these
are just a couple quick examples and I
really show them just to point out how
why the use cases are how varying the
datasets are now think how different the
code and the models have to be there's
not just a magic model and there's not a
magic data set so when our customers are
building these types of models you know
what are they coming to us and asking
for
well they care deeply about the physical
world a lot of them are fortune 500
companies they care about physical
infrastructure but a lot of them are
very concerned about security as well we
all kind of we all are and often they're
wanting to train a model so make their
own intellectual property off their data
which is their intellectual property and
they want to know that their model is
isolated from other customers and safe
and secure and so we want to enable them
to be able to build and train and test
those models about all of our petabytes
of data so it kind of has to live next
to the data and know that the security
isolation isn't going to slow down or or
cause delays in the training and then
they might have confidence that they'll
be able to that other users of the
system aren't going to be able to access
their data or their intellectual
property so what challenges do we have
when trying to build that type of a
platform well each model is executing
someone else on one of our users machine
learning code so we need to be able to
execute that securely and at scale each
model has very different requirements
some of these models take our very CPU
intensive others are very memory
intensive maybe some of them need to use
a GPU these are pretty big in scale I'll
come in most mornings and I don't see 10
or 20 course running on our graph on a
graph I see tens of thousands of CPU
cores that are running that somebody's
going out and building models or testing
testing models against those data sets
so it needs to scale and be efficient
and you know we thought of originally of
doing this through isolating with gke
node pools and making one node pool per
customer but that kind of runs into a
lot of limitations once you start
getting a few customers we thought of
using a cluster a whole kubernetes
cluster per per customer that also runs
into a lot of implementations and we
wanted to do this where startup we don't
have just infinite resources most of you
don't either and so we're trying to do
this as efficiently as possible from a
cost perspective and still get that that
security so we want to leverage
kubernetes scheduler to get that really
tight bin packing so on GCP there's a
lot of great tools for data and things
like data exfiltration we leverage
things like VPC service controls to to
prevent data exfiltration but for models
and model execution we need to execute
that user's code so the first thing we
do is we carve out a user name space for
each user and then we restrict what they
can talk to they cannot talk to the
kubernetes control plane under the hood
they can only talk to our Descartes Labs
api's so that's a really important
separation and then our decart Labs API
is are talking to the kubernetes control
plane and that's how we're scaling up
and down the workloads and then for our
decart labs api is to get visibility
into what's going on to be able to do
things like rate limiting or security
telemetry that's all handled through Sto
our user workloads as Ian just showed
those go in a gke sandbox node pool and
so as it's been mentioned that improves
a lot with security it limits syscalls
to the kernel it separates each user and
it's a lot more efficient than making
their own node pool for every single
customer for us we get much improved on
the cost side we we run most of our
workloads on things
preemptable VMS so that's critical to be
able to use that and make that efficient
in terms of pricing and we get the
tighter bin packing of those workloads
and in still improve isolation so how
did we enable GAE sandbox as was
mentioned you basically set the sandbox
type to G advisor when you do a a node
pool creation and what's really great
was we didn't change our code we didn't
have to have our users change their code
to get this degree of isolation and we
could run this on an existing cluster we
simply just made a new node pool so it's
it's very easy to get this started and
just start testing your workloads and
see how they do so the next question you
might say is well how did it actually
perform for these types of machine
learning workloads a basic test case so
we didn't we've only tested this on a
few workloads but the startup cost is
around about a second and you know we're
running models in minutes two hours
today so we can live with a second and
then those rough models are about 1%
difference in terms of overall
performance so I mean to be honest I
would say that's within the margin of
error in our measurements so that's more
than adequate and so this is now
available and we're making this
available to all of our customers today
with that I'll hand it to Yoshi thank
you so much Tim it's great to see the
this is not like a demonstration it's
writing in your real real system seeing
the value so I was Tim quickly touch I'm
gonna talk a little dig a little bit
deeper the performance on to kind of
tone correct um Jiki sandbox is about
like boosting your performance of all
about like providing isolation and
providing that sort of isolation or
national defense we're gonna take some
cycles from your work clothes and get
back this defense with ease and which
will lead to the cost efficiency that
Tim just described so for machining
warning workloads like Tim introduced
yes these are you know some
this is a kind of data from the machine
learning inference work clothes and our
prediction and a tight tight these types
of CPU and memory kind of oriented work
clothes the cycles that we need to
provide to give you back the isolation
that Tim talked about or roughly about
two to three percent of the warhead so
if you're wondering like you know the
work clothes like you have similar
workloads like Tim's this should be a
very good kind of good fit for you
because we're just only treat 2% of a
cycle you get these kind of benefit up
front now we're close like Redis I think
we know a lot you know we mean a lot of
you may know about there it is in memory
data store one of the most popular
sample workloads on GK these type of
work those needs 20 to 30% of cyclists
from the work from you to return the
benefit but if you have like SAS and
multi-tenancy for example if you have
Redis instance for each customer where
you today you create a different cluster
or nose even then GK Sanwa should still
be able to help you greatly to provide
you this the bin packing capability at
you know with ease lastly I'm gonna
ensure about the ffmpeg and then
WordPress use case also ffmpeg is a
well-known on transcoding open source
program and we're pressed as you're
gonna in already showed is a blog and
website web hosting platform there are
actually both Network and file oriented
work clothes however the way they do
they are actually different compared to
a wordpress which will issue I win a one
by one ffmpeg actually gathers IO very
nice way so that GK sandbox does I have
to say too many cycle from from you it's
only about 5% to actually to you know
five percent is that pretty much the the
cycles that we need to give you back
this isolation which will be to the
which will lead to the cost efficiency
so if you're wondering like which okay
where I mean how interesting GG sandbox
but which were close will be the great
fit
actually this few our number I oh should
be a very good guideline to figure out
you know to find a work clothes that
will be very very kind of a benefit
by using GG sandbox okay
just wrapping up then so GK sign we
introduce GG sandbox this will be
publicly available in late April
all the things are queued up waiting for
after next that you know to to unlock
everything it GG sandbox will provide
defense and depth to your cabrini spot
with ease no application changes like
two lines which Tim show is exactly what
you have to do it we grapefruity me
interested in assassin multi-tenancy and
it's based on open source advisor which
in taco bell and we put a lot of effort
in to provide a better experience as
product all you have to do is to just a
turn and create a note pool and turning
on in your paws back rest of things will
happen behind a scene and we also add
actually a lot of optimization around
performance so if you're wondering which
work we're close to use we're you know
tell for GG sandbox please take a you
know look at the numbers that are kind
of shared today that's really thank you
very much for listening
if you have any questions please comment
we don't have like less than a minute
more than happy to take a question it's
offline so you know fufufu i'll feel
free to come to new commentators thank
you so much
[Applause]
[Music]